we want a trade deal with Europe we want
to be good neighbors with our European
friends but we desperately seek a
referendum so that we can set this
country free from political Union and
there is no third way there is no
renegotiation of any value that is to be
had in Brussels now our position is
perfectly clear we want our country back
we want an Australian style point system
so that we can choose the quantity and
type of people who come to live work and
settle in our country so we simply won't
allow foreign criminals to come into
this country and all migrants that come
to Britain will have to have their own
health insurance and nobody will be able
to access the benefit system until
they've been in Britain for five years
paid their taxes and obeyed the law
something of course that is again only
possible outside membership of the
European Union we still campaigning for
no tax on the minimum wage up to
earnings of 13 thousand pounds a year we
want to raise the threshold at which
people start paying 40p tax to 55
thousand pounds a year we want to
introduce a new 30p tax band for those
earning between 45 and 55 thousand
pounds a year and of course we want to
remove inheritance tax which is now one
of the biggest barriers to young people
getting on to the housing ladder
we have pragmatic plans to put forward
savings which by the end of the next
Parliament would amount to 32 billion
pounds a year we do that by radically
cutting the foreign aid budget we do it
by ending EU contributions which are
wholly unnecessary to us doing trade we
do it by scrapping vanity projects such
as hs2 and we do it by revisiting the
Barnett formula despite the fact the
other three part is a sworn to maintain
it we do it by revisiting and changing
the Barnett formula to give Wales in
England a better and fairer deal you
can't is fully committed to the founding
principles of the National Health
Service and we are the one party with a
costed plan to increase spending by up
to three
in pounds a-year we want to train 20,000
extra nurses eight thousand extra GPS
3,000 more midwives and the need to do
this is great as our rapidly increased
population has put an intolerable strain
on health services in this country and
we also want to end the tax on illness
by scrapping hospital parking charges
but what we're also offering is a well
thought through planned brownfield
building revolution that would give us 1
million new homes by 2020 we think
defense does matter we think it's there
in the hearts of the British people and
we will commit again fully costed to
spending the 2% that is required by NATO
we will spend 2% on our defense spending
initially but would look to increase it
substantially after that